Mes amis...
L'ennemi est proche.
L'ennemi est nombreux.
Ses murmures se font entendre.
Ses pas se font chaque jours plus lourds, plus proches, plus distincts.
Puisque Yara Greyjoy nous a refusé son aide...
Nous allons devoir redoubler de vigilance et de courage !
Ouais !
Si Salladhor Saan dit vrai...
L'ennemi compte nous envahir par les côtes.
C'est pourquoi l'aide de Lord Davos nous sera précieuse.
Nous devrons bien évidemment nous passer du soutien de Lord Renly.
Et comme Eddard Stark...
Robb stark...
Lord Rodrigue...
Et Jeor Mormont avant nous...
Nous devrons combattre !
Ouais !
La guerre s'annonce longue et rude.
C'est pourquoi la vigilance est de mise.
Vous !
Allez prévenir Brynden Tully que nous sommes en position.
Oui bah... Je vais y aller, j'attends qu'elle ait fini son discours.
J'ai fini.
Eh bah, allez.
Un quelconque tourment vous habite-t-il ?
Non, non j'y vais....
Pourquoi allez-vous vers l'Ouest ?
Mais je sais pas qui c'est ! Voilà.
Pardonnez-moi ?
Non mais machin, là. Le mec que je dois aller chercher...
Son nom ça me dit quelque chose, mais je vois pas quelle tête il a.
Enfin, il s'agit de l'oncle de Catelyn Stark et d'Edmure Tully.
Mais je sais pas qui c'est non plus !
Je vous implore de mesurer l'importance de la tâche qui vous incombe.
Je vous rappelle que Lord Davos a mobilisé ses troupes pour nous soutenir !
C'est lequel Davos déjà ?
Il est blanc avec une barbe.
Ah, c'est le blanc avec une barbe.
D'accord.
Non mais on est tous blanc avec une barbe !
Non c'est pour ça, les meufs je me rappelle un peu mieux tu vois.
Brienne, Cersei, Khaleesi...
Ah ouais mais non.
Elle s'appelle Daenerys.
Khaleesi c'est son titre honorifique.
Je me trompe pas ?
Le gros geek...
Lors Davos est un des plus fidèles alliés de Lord Stannis !
Ouais. Stannis c'est le mec qui s'est tapé la meuf qui a de la fumée qui sort de la chatte ?
Ah non mais si je vous jure !
Y a genre 3 ans, il y a une meuf elle a écarté les jambes et...
Stannis !
Est le frère de Robert Barathéon !
Ah bah voilà, lui je sais qui c'est.
C'est le père du gamin sans jambes qui traine toujours avec le gars là...
Comment il s'appelle le mec qui dit tout le temps "Hodor" ?
Hodor.
Ah il répète son nom en fait ?
Non mais comme il disait tout le temps "Hodor", on l'a appelé comme ça.
Ok. C'est pas très respectueux...
Je veux dire le mec clairement handicapé, vous vous foutez de sa g...
Non mais vous venez d'arriver vous ou quoi ?
Mais non ! En plus je suis là depuis le début !
Mais dès que je retenais le nom d'un gars il crevait, donc j'ai laissé tombé quoi...
Et en plus, ils s'appellent tous Lord Machin...
Donc si on faisait prénom-nom, ce serait déjà plus simple à retenir.
Si vous vous ne vous estimez pas à la hauteur de votre mission, je trouverai quelqu'un pour vous remplacer.
Bah ouais j'avoue...
Et vous serez emprisonné pour trahison.
Et bah j'allais partir justement, donc...
Voilà.
Entendez-moi sur le champ, Brinden Tully...
Car j'apporte un message de la plus haute importance.
L'ennemi approche et...
Hodor !
C'est Hodor.
Il y a...
Il y a aucune chance que vous soyer Brinden Tully qui me fait une blague ?
Hodor !
Mmh, mmh, ok.
Euh le... Sinon le chemin peut-être ?
Pour aller à la rencontre de Brinden Tully.
Hodor.
Mmh, mmh, d'accord.
Alors sinon, je pense à un truc, à 3 on dit le truc pour voir si on pense à la même chose.
Un, deux, trois !
Du pain.
Hodor !
Ouais, j'avais dit du pain moi... Donc c'est vous Hodor, du coup ?
Ouais, allez c'est bon.